hi this is Peter Russell of university
of story I also teach at UCLA in
Pepperdine but my main job is being a
story doctor in Hollywood and over the
last five years most of my work has gone
from working on movies to working on
television now when I began to work on
television five years ago more than
movies I kind of panicked because I'd
been working on films for 10 years and I
had developed a whole set of tools for
movies and I wasn't sure if I was even
gonna be able to help television
creators but the good news was
everything I'd learned about movies
worked in television everything the
television of course is different in
television the characters don't change
everything but the characters change and
the other thing is you can tell a lot
more than you show but all the patterns
I discovered that work in the genres and
movies also work in the genres of
television so what I wanted to talk to
you today a little bit about is how to
take a classic movie and to analyze it
and to break it down and we're gonna use
the Dark Knight to do so because all
these patterns gonna work in your
television show - the thriller patterns
and the action patterns I'm gonna talk
about today
work in television as well but and
because television is so full of dark
heroes now and even anti-heroes dark
heroes like mr. robot anti-heroes like
Breaking Bad I want and there's more
coming by the way many more anti he was
coming I want to talk to you about how
Chris Nolan who is a genius of a movie
maker has made an antihero in the show
dark night in the movie dark night that
is so brilliant that it shows you how
you can create an antihero not just in
movies if you want to make movies but
also in television I'm also gonna be
lecturing in a few weeks on how to turn
a great film into a television show
using Fargo as an example but I want to
use dark night tonight because Chris
Nolan is brilliant he's a genius and
nobody does the anti-hero story as well
as him now in action you want to
understand a couple of things in an
action movie the villains obvious you
see it from the very
getting and in okay so there's three
kinds of action heroes there is the
rites of passage hero who heals his
wound for the course of the movie this
is Iron Man there is the there is the
superhero this is Leonidas in 300 he
never really has an emotional change by
the way that can also be a villain
superhero like Jake Johnson in and Don
Jake he's a comic or it can be the kind
of villain that you have with Jake
Gyllenhaal in Nightcrawler he never
really changes he just gets stronger and
stronger as a villain you also have a
third kind of action hero and that is
the hero we're gonna talk about today
the antihero now he's the guy who starts
out good but becomes evil for
sympathetic reasons this by the way is
Walter White and Breaking Bad and this
by the way is Harvey Dent in Dark Knight
The Dark Knight I'm using because Nolan
is so brilliant and antihero is simply a
hero who turns into a villain that's it
you want to use this kind of action hero
if you're writing a hip dark story with
a disturbing a provocative theme to
appeal to the hipster intellectual crowd
as well as the traditional action
audience so you get a mix it's brilliant
to do that we're going to show you this
hero in a movie I'm gonna logline the
movie for you right now now a movie
logline is about a hero who changes its
the entire story of the movie from the
perspective of the hero but that's
exactly what you get here let me read
you the logline for Dark Knight when a
brave but self-righteous and wrathful
District Attorney is tapped by a
superhero to save a city from corruption
and a super villain he becomes so angry
at the supervillains hideous crimes that
he becomes evil himself and starts
murdering innocent people until the
super hero must step in kill him and
take the blame for crimes now who is the
hero in the Dark Knight it's not Batman
it's Harvey Dent the DA but remember in
action the villain is insanely powerful
I just did a consulate with a really
brilliant guy new rider very very big
actor
who wants to write and he wrote a
brilliant story but he left out his
villain in a lot of genres guys you want
to have the villain as the thing that
drives all your action even if you don't
see it at first and the Dark Knight has
an insanely powerful villain in the
Joker the hero is an antihero it's
Harvey Dent two-face Harvey Dent is a
guy who starts out good and he becomes
evil and he does so for reasons that
we're gonna talk about are the same
reasons we voted President Obama and
office this is about how the world works
anti-heroes begin to make the wrong
decisions for the right reasons because
their core wound gets activated by the
villain he changes to dark from light
for sympathetic reasons now Michael
Corleone II and the Godfather is an
antihero why how does Michael Corleone a
start out on the movie he's a war hero
and when he goes to his father's house
he tells his fiancee I'm not like them
Kay I'm different why does Michael
Corleone have become dark sympathetic
raises remember what they are and
Michael wants to save his family this is
the key secret to creating right Anna
you are guys make him a guy we can care
about if you don't you end up with a
really bad and I you know what he cares
about so what do we do this here that's
Anakin Skywalker in Star Wars okay great
anti-heroes now when you have a action
hero you want to give them traits what
are Harvey Dent traits in this movie
he's brave as hell he's a risk taker
he's self-righteous and he's willing to
cut corners now where do we first see
him we see him in a courtroom fighting
against the corruption in Gotham City
with his fiancee at his side and when
the guy on the stand pulls a gun on him
Harvey didn't just grabs the gun pulls
it out of his hand and tells the judge I
don't even want to take a break
I got a prosecute this guy and then I'm
gonna
play golf this afternoon and the whole
courtroom applauds why what is the power
of the Dark Knight because it's us you
know that Los Angeles is a corrupt city
don't you you know that our country has
a lot of corruption in it don't you
who's fighting it
who's fighting it nobody has a vigilante
fighting it
why is Batman important in this story
because Batman is a vigilante fighting
the corrupt forces of Los Angeles
fighting the corrupt forces that give
you a parking ticket for $900 that gets
you into court and out for $4,000 when
he knew he did nothing wrong
bribery on every level how do we solve
it Harvey did we'll solve it he's
courageous righteous and good that's how
an antihero starts out he's using his
bravery for light but remember he's got
a core wound all great heroes do Harvey
Dent's core wound is that he his the
people he loved died he can never love
now remember in this corrupt City Batman
is a vigilante and we see that in the
Batman television shows too when your
world is corrupt and every official you
meet is corrupt just like every cop
you're gonna meet in Los Angeles you're
probably gonna have a bad experience
with who do you turn to for salvation
you can't turn to a cop who do you turn
to maybe it turned to somebody you hire
who is a vigilante who's outside the
corrupt system well that's Batman
so in Dark Knight Batman decides to run
Harvey Dent for office he wants Harvey
Dent to come in and clean up Gotham City
because Batman is a vigilante can't do
it so what does he do
you